Dude, I-- I thought
he was in a band.
I didn't know this was
gonna be, like an improv show.
Yeah, me too,
I don't know.
What's hotter than a pink
dick with a sense of humor?
I mean, a black
dick, but...
You know that you're so
anti-racist sometimes
that you're actually
really racist?
Huh.
(man)
All right, thank
you all for coming.
We are Statutory Crepe.
Everything you're about to
see will be fully improvised.
All we need to get
started is one word.
(man)
Eggroll!
I heard "eggroll."
Dude.
Mom.
Yes, son?
I need to talk to
you about my penis.
Yes, son?
I love answering questions
about penises,
even though
I have a vagina!
Ha ha ha!
How much for
this shirt?
I can--
One million dollars.
I'm embarrassed
that I'm here.
I'm embarrassed that
he was inside of me.
(animal noises)
I'm not watching
this by myself, get--
(Ilana)
You should come
down here.
Sit in your seat,
you brought me here.
Oh, my God.
Scene!
We're gonna take
a quick break and be back
with another hour of
Statutory Crepe!
Woohoo!
(Ilana)
Oh, my God, that was the
worst thing I've ever seen.
I feel like I've
been hate-crimed.
Oh, my God!
The dot's back!
(Abbi)
Ew, it's still
in Times Square!
I bet the freak
was seeing a play
and turned it
off to be polite.
Oh, my God, dude.
Times Square,
Central Park?
Upper East Side,
means it's a tourist.
Ew!
The dot's moving
down Eighth Ave.
What tourist spot
is down there?
I don't know, but
let's get out of here
before Jerry Lewis
sees you again.
(Ilana)
Oh, my God, oh!
I've been
pulled back in.
It's too-- I can't--
I can't not.
I can't say no.
Okay, you go with
Dr. Evil, because
I just figured out where
the thief took my phone,
the last place
every tourist goes.
The airport?
No, not--
Not literally
the last place.
Magnolia Bakery.
Right, right,
right, right.
Right?
Yeah, do it.
Okay, I'm going.
Get your hot piece.
All right, I'm going.
Get it.
Hey!
Oh! Oh.